Directors Joe and Anthony Russo combined arguably
the most confusing element of Avengers: Endgame
with one of the most heart-wrenching moments
in the last few minutes of the film.
Chris Evans' Steve Rogers returned from his
final time travel mission as an old man, gifted
his shield to Anthony Mackie's Sam Wilson,
and kept coy about his wedding band…that
we all know was a sign he got married to Hayley
Atwell's Peggy Carter.
Once the fuzzy feelings that the scene inspired
faded, though, fans were left scratching their
heads and wondering how exactly Old Man Cap
got back to the main timeline, as his appearance
seemingly contradicts the rules of time travel
as previously outlined in the movie.
Finally, more than three months after viewers
first watched Endgame up on the big screen,
we have the definitive answer.
The Russo Brothers recently held an Ask Me
Anything session on Reddit, where they detailed
how the grizzled Captain America found his
way back to the main timeline without completely
shattering the established time travel theory
the Ancient One stated early on in Endgame.
A fan asked the Russos how Cap came back to
the present after returning the Infinity Stones
to their respective places in the past, and
requested some clarification on the rules
of time travel.
According to the Ancient One, when someone
takes a Stone from its original place and
travels through time, they create a branched
timeline that doesn't alter the past.
When Steve Rogers returned the Stones following
the big battle against Thanos, he wore a quantum
suit and used a Pym Particle to travel back
in time.
But when the older Steve appeared on the park
bench at the end of Endgame, he wasn't in
a quantum suit.
Did Cap figure out a way to come back to the
present without using the same method that
sent him to the past?
Did he live out his life with Peggy in the
main timeline, thus creating two separate
Captain Americas and countering the rules
of time travel, or did he marry her in an
alternate timeline and keep everything intact?
The Russos confirmed on Reddit that Cap, quote,
"would have had to have worn the quantum suit"
and used a Pym Particle to re-join the present
timeline, just as he needed to do to jump
back to the past.
But the reason why he isn't sporting the silvery
suit on the bench is because, quite simply,
he took it off earlier.
According to the Russos, quote, "that is not
the exact moment to which he returned."
So, there you have it: Cap did indeed return
to the main timeline using the quantum suit
and a Pym Particle, but he was hanging around
in the year 2023 as a wrinkly, white-haired
old man at least long enough to change out
of the suit and into something your bird-watching
grandfather would wear.
"Time travel!"
This explanation indicates that Joe and Anthony
Russo are of the opinion that Steve and Peggy
reunited, got married, and shared a full and
happy life filled with many evenings spent
dancing in their living room all in a timeline
alternate to the main one of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
Joe Russo even told Entertainment Weekly in
May 2019,
"If Cap were to go back into the past and
live there, he would create a branched reality."
However, not everyone involved with Endgame
agrees with that assessment.
Screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely have maintained their belief that
Steve's grand plan to finally spend his life
with Peggy happened in the main timeline,
meaning that there are two Captain Americas
in the MCU.
Just after the release of Endgame, Markus
and McFeely sat down with Fandango's Erik
Davis, who asked if Cap's ending means that,
quote, "an old Captain America was hanging
out this whole time while another Captain
America was saving the day?"
Markus confirmed that he personally rejects
the idea that Steve was ever in an alternate
timeline, saying,
"We are not experts on time travel, but the
Ancient One specifically states that when
you take an Infinity Stone out of a timeline,
it creates a new timeline.
So Steve going back and just being there would
not create a new timeline.
So I reject the 'Steve is in an alternate
reality' theory.
I do believe that there is simply a period
in world history from about '48 to now where
there are two Steve Rogers.
And anyway, for a large chunk of that, one
of them is frozen in ice.
So it's not like they'd be running into each
other."
It's hard to say whether the two directors
or the two writers are more accurate here,
since this is all science-fiction, but the
Russos' explanation better aligns with the
rules of time travel established in Endgame.
Even so, Markus and McFeely have said that
Cap's ending is open for interpretation.
Though he and McFeely prefer their theory
to the Russos', Markus has said that the issue
of whether Steve's life with Peggy happened
in an alternate reality or in the main MCU
timeline is, quote, "a question with many
answers."
So, mystery sort of solved?
We'll leave it at that.
"It was beautiful."
"I'm happy for you."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.